Tilly had waited decades for this
seminal moment
the arrest of Matthew Messina dinaro the
mafia boss who had been on the run for
30 years
came from medical attention to this
clinic in the Sicilian city of paloma he
came with a false name but there were a
hundred officers waiting for him his
arrest confirmed by the police words
many thought they would never hear
on the 16th of January Italian police in
the investigation coordinated by
Palermo's attorney arrested The Fugitive
Matteo Messina denado at a health clinic
where he was undergoing some medical
treatment
[Applause]
on the streets a joyful reaction and
thanks for the police Messina Donato is
a feared name with a dreadful reputation
he's been linked to scores of murders
including bombings in Italy and the
killing of two people who are supposed
to be investigating him
he's already been sentenced in absence
to life in prison he inspires fear the
Italian Prime Minister came to Sicily
acclaiming the arrest as a beautiful day
for Italy
it's a day of celebration for us we can
tell our children that the mafia can be
defeated we haven't won the war we have
not defeated the mafia yet but this was
a fundamental battle to win and it's a
hard blow for organized crime
but how was he caught many appraising
Relentless police work others suspect a
more cynical reason what we can see
historically is that when people are
kind of found it's because there are
different balances that have taken place
whereby perhaps they have no longer have
political protection perhaps the level
of silence and Associates around them
kind of is no longer there so I just I'm
rather cynical as to why this happens
now
Messina Donato was Swept Away in a
police Convoy and taken to a secret
location Italy's most feared criminal
may never be free again
Adam Parsons Sky News